COMMITTEE MEETING FOR MONDAY
MARCH SECOND IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. USUALLY ADVISER TO AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE HAS ALSO
BEEN TO. AFFECT FOR PEACE THE
ROLL CALL. BUT HERE CUNNINGHAM
CARILLO FLORA GRAY. CAMP HERE
THANK. MATHIS HERE PARKS RAMOS
SEC READ. WICKS HERE WE HAVE
CHLOE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AMERICANS CHEN. THANK YOU FOR
I'M AS WORK SEC AND MISTER.
COMMON PARDON FROM I. MICHAEL
THERE IS A SECOND MARRIAGE
SECTOR CALLED COOLEY HI COOLEY
I CUTCARILLO FLOOR. OR I
KAMLAGER AMONG. AND. BASICALLY
YEAH.
I'M MYSTERIES ARE I THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HAVE
YOU THE ROLE. YES THANK CONSENT
CONSERVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PERFECT VERY GOOD WELL THANK
THANK ON CONSENT. WE RAN A
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE SAME.